à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non aucune idée d'avoir 58 12 de ouf sur
fond de chevron ont tous impatiemment
j'ai posé juste une question dans un
instant et tu me répondras je vais te
laisser le soin d'y répondre mais je
voudrais là la vérité aspyr espère et
attend que si tu m'en sépare type
d'accord alors on s'est tous serré la
nouvelle vous êtes un spécialiste média
un spécial de la barca et les balances
ton post un spécialiste politique
maintenant il va depuis quelques temps
vous êtes aussi devenu un spécialiste ça
se voit de la mode
évidemment puisque des vous voyez
quelqu'un vous ne pouvez pas vous
empêcher de lui donner des conseils pour
s'habiller pour se coiffer ou se raser
la preuve avec ce nouveau laurier vous
emporter en tant que remarque du
shopping son fonds de commerce et
baskets le jean est tous assez très
frais fréon grella tgo ce beau de ouf
malade
franchement on dirait enfin un médecin
genre on en voit demander du dap un brin
c'est juste qu'elle est projet physique
en ce moment on est sur une offre est
hissé au son du piano c'est au niveau de
la plus con c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
qu'est ce qu'on va faire quoi là on est
pas couper les cheveux depuis 1978 la
tête de ma mère à la des sauterelles et
[Applaudissements]
on voit que ça vous amuse de critiquer
les tenues des oeufs savoie mais la
grande question que l'on se pose c'est
est-ce que le look dossier là demain est
irréprochable
non non c'est brive je demande et moi ce
soir oui bon pour répondre à cette
question j'ai décidé de vous inscrire
aux rênes du shopping regarder
sans chercher les mots
c'est l'un des enjeux auxquels planète
je suis la combinaison ne va pas à sa
morphologie
oui sinon bibring franchement au bar en
bar le k'fé fois ci n'en parle jamais
des canards mais à part à ces deux là
sinon oui à tout va bien je n'aime pas
trop le ton ironique de ces rues qui se
moque de vous par ce petit magnéto quand
il aura papier dans l'injection directe
et influenceurs de mode tom et battu la
ramènera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez si avoir d'amitié pour quelqu'un
c'est fayoter on arrête fait simplement
amis ou scène beaucoup tout simplement
que je comprends voilà mr droite a
compris eva dimanche alors vous savez
que j'aime bien passer du temps devant
les émissions de téléréalité ça me
permet de rêver quand je vois les
paysages paradisiaques et de
cauchemarder quand j'entends parler les
candidats et comme d'hab je le remets le
laurier de ceux qui maîtrisent tellement
mal de france et qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils parlent pas notre langue de notre
état d'esprit l'aurait fait si tu vois
ce n'est pas de fumée sans feu
oui répondent qu'ils brassent dunois les
légumes ils sont pas propres et brillant
comme sûrement marché à moi les légumes
et seront ils sont de la terre limite de
temps il s'est arrêté à l'époque que
jérusalem s'arrête et lui s'il se sent
que ça dure ce soir je sais que l'âge de
gènes d'un nouveau lieu et j'allais voir
comment il va a fait de gros progrès en
anglais dans la culture du riz c'est au
delà de l'extraordinaire série contre
toute attente bleury ça pousse pas dans
les arbres
simplement dans une rivière payet
rivière
lysiane tu regardes ça dibril regarder
ça d'hybrides la trauma l'impression
chaque matin à 7h20 qu'alibi novelli se
couche
elle rate donc de grands moments de
télévision sur ses news alors bien sûr
parler de l'interview politique de jean
pierre elkabbach
le gars qui fait aussi peur que mon prof
de maths en terminale es un évidemment
et ça tombe bien parce qu'il fait peur à
ses invités aussi je précise que rien
truqués dans ce que vous allez voir rien
des trucs et je remets à jean pierre
elkabbach que laurier du gars qui à 50
ans de carrière
mais qui sait toujours pas quand il est
à l'antenne ou non sans talent est
capable je lève très tôt alors il fait
la sieste jusqu'au dernier au monde
génériques
cette occasion de la visite genre punk à
bâcher comment il a plus de sourcils que
de cheveux alors quand il se croit hors
antenne il se recoiffer source il est
l'invité tout de suite toujours bien
al-kadhafi jean-pierre il est tellement
pressé de faire saisine ferroukhi les
commence toujours hors antenne donc on
n'a jamais le début des entretiens c'est
incroyable et sonneurs de l'équipe
loiseau directeur de campagne
numéro 6 clés qui viennent le dire
j'adore ce jour d'hui la violer
vars va être le jour symbolique et a
qu'une seule fo jean pierre elkabbach a
commencé son interview à temps c'est
quand il ressortait 7 à vis des
politiques
cherry lane où là bonjour merci bonjour
de quoi je me mêle
[Applaudissements]
cet effort il faut après les fortes et a
donc salué bush et de très belle façon
au mail de ce qui nous regarde
c'était une des français vers sigean
mille personnes tous les français mais
heureusement que vous êtes là
franchement merci je regarde depuis
quelques temps vous êtes dans le cinoche
non non pas trop un petit peu vous avez
vu les dégâts par exemple est-ce que
vous avez produit un film en thaïlande
récemment où il ya quelques années
peut-être en thaïlande ou pas produit de
films mais non j'ai cru parce qu'en fait
je tombais sur un film où le budget
déguisement est aussi faible que dans
tpm paix c'est le laurier de la pire
transformation en loup garou du cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quoi passer tout de suite
l'élection du tarn badaoui le tarbes
abad où l'on se dit est-ce que cyril
c'est que le tarbes avec respect qu'on
explique c'est celui qui tacle le plus
des autres ici même ça peut être un
chroniqueur ça peut être vous et depuis
le début c'est toujours vous qui gagne à
deux ou trois titres ont gagné trois
fois trois excellents donc là ça serait
le quatrième la quatrième victoire a
souri le champion des champions le
maestro est ce que vous pensez à
regarder votre couronne ne pense pas non
évidemment je vous remets pour la énième
fois le lauréat du tabac si je vous veux
mais il faut lui dire toi parce que si
je me suis je lance à la peau même si je
les aime beaucoup
n'hésitez pas tout ce qu'on aime
l'élégance de l'élégance à la wii la
gaffe
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait un rêve érotique je vous jure
que c'est vrai arrête sur isabelle là je
vous donnais à fond ça se passe aux
etats unis c'est une femme qui a gagné
le loto écoutez bien le montant qu'elle
a gagné à lui je vous donne l'info tout
de suite magnéto écoutez le mobile ôta
[Applaudissements]
ya deux heures était chauffeur lui faire
un bisou à vraiment bien sûr un raymond
justement qu'elle opère et raymond qui
sera avec nous lundi
robles repose il est un exercice ce soir
voilà il avait besoin de se reposer un
peu et raymond sera de retour lundi dans
l'émission mon chéri que j'aime merci
vous avez été formidables merci madame
je voulais propres d'un petit journal
mais non je regarde donc merci beaucoup